how long have we been dating we've had
like two years ago we've been dating
like five months it's like 10 months so
9 ko9 10 months we met through words
well I met you on a booze cruise
it's organizing an event and he was
mentoring there but you had been
secretly checking me out for a while
yeah I went full circle to reorganize
this event and he actually helped this
time so he was the cute boy at work and
then I went to a bar with my friend and
she was like just ask him out and I was
like okay and then we started dating
like a couple months ago this summer oh
we could book cuttin yourself my
facebook messaged him and we went out so
now i'm tinder I didn't do pretty well I
know Claire I never did pretty well
because she wears like a very distinct
perfume purple it smells like purple say
I'm about 80% confident I feel like I
know how my girlfriend smells but you
never know until you get out there in
the field she saw floral she's the thing
with flowers like sort of lavender II
smell yeah I know I don't know it's a
little flowery a little sweet I guess
she sprays me with her perfume sometimes
to be a pain I'm going to completely Ace
this if I'm wrong I'm probably gonna be
punished afterwards if I'm wrong I'd
hope I'm not in trouble I hope it's a
fun experiment but you never know when
we get home tonight not first time we've
been asked that
[Music]
Oh how far to my left or right you not
I'm not really good at describing smells
slightly sweet not a lot of scent there
I mean it's New York so you kind of have
to like discredit like the subway funk
I've dug net to remove that from every
participant she doesn't smell like that
I felt like some curly hair or something
which does not have baby I mean I leaned
it up I got a smell mm-hmm she smell
like that it's not the smell I'm looking
for just be real right I don't think so
it could be though I'm feeling less
confident now that I'm now that I'm here
doing it I smell something familiar
I'm kind of floral I know a little more
flowery but this is the last participant
so now I'm realizing that I don't think
any of them are my girlfriend oh no this
is some elaborate trick I think this is
that yeah that's the one I'm gonna say
this is Claire it's it's close I think
between 1 & 2
duh Alko number one should I get it yeah
yes that way bunk I think I did pretty
well I'm like crying it was this easy
slam dunk it was a close call honestly
between 1 and 2 as I went on it was that
Supreme Court ruling on pornography that
said I can't describe it but I know it
when I see it
you know same thing with smells I can't
describe the smells but I know it when I
smell it
[Music]
you